a la cumbre de los tres amigos el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
recibió en la casa blanca a sus
homólogos de canadá y méxico revitalizar
la cooperación regional fue el principal
objetivo para afrontar problemáticas
comunes y
juntos estamos abordando problemas
problemas mutuos que afectan a nuestra
gente controlando la pandemia impulsando
una recuperación económica inclusiva y
abordando la migración
lópez obrador agradeció la propuesta del
mandatario estadounidense de regularizar
la situación migratoria de más de 11
millones de personas que viven y
trabajan en eeuu pero apuntó a más en
términos de migración y comercio y hacer
a un lado mitos y prejuicios por ejemplo
y rechazar a migrantes
cuando para crecer se necesita de fuerza
el trabajo que en realidad no se tiene
con suficiencia y en estados unidos y en
canadá
porque no estudia la demanda de mano de
obra y abrir ordenadamente el flujo
migratorio
obrador propuso que el restablecimiento
económico se logre fortaleciendo la
producción regional y así reducir la
compra de mercancías procedentes de asia
aunque ni trudeau ni bailén comentaron
sobre las propuestas de lópez obrador a
adherirse a soto logramos entendernos en
varios temas desde las cadenas de
suministro o incluso nuestras relaciones
de aquí a 120 días pero también sobre
nuestras estrategias a nivel
internacional en la región indo pacífico
por ejemplo los líderes acordaron
medidas como la donación de vacunas para
países latinoamericanos la lucha contra
el tráfico de armas y el fortalecimiento
de la cadena de suministros regionales
la próxima reunión de líderes se
realizará en méxico en el 2022